okay why don't we get started today
we're gonna come full circle back to the
first lecture so we in the first lecture
we talked by we started by drawing a
supply and demand graph we've now spent
the last few weeks explaining where
supply and demand curves come from and
now we're gonna talk about the supply
and demand curves you know what do they
know did they know things let's find out
so no one no one on that okay thank you
alright so let's start by talking about
shocking the supply and demand curves
shocking the supply and demand curves
that was a Bojack horseman reference for
those who missed that okay let's let's
talk about shocking the supply and
demand curves so let's start with a
review of the supply and demand
framework that we introduced in the
first lecture so let's go back to figure
9 1 we've got the market for gasoline
okay on the x-axis is big Q quantity of
gases is a market level diagram on the
y-axis the price of gas and as we said
the first lecture to supply curve that's
upward sloping representing the fact
that higher prices call forth more
supply we now know where that comes from
we know that what happens is when
there's a higher price firms can now
afford to move up the marginal cost
curve which is a supply curve so we know
where that comes from
we've demand curve which is downward
sloping higher prices lead to less
demand we know where that comes from
we know that it's the price of a good
Rises through both income and
substitution effects for normal goods
good sumers who want less of it so
whenever that comes from so we now have
derived these and we're back where we
started in equilibrium so let's actually
start by asking what happens let's say I
start by asking as we move forward how
do I want to think about these curves
and the way I think about them is we
want to think about the demand curve
want to think about these as willingness
to play pay and willingness to supply
curse so think about the demand curve as
a willingness to pay curve how much are
you willing to pay to get the next unit
of
doors how much is the market willing to
pay to get the next unit of the good
okay and the supply curve is willing to
supply okay an equilibrium is the point
where consumers willingness to pay for
the next unit of the good meets the
suppliers willing to supply the next
unit of the good when those are equal
we're in equilibrium so that's kind of
where we start now let's asking now
let's ask what happens as these cars
shift so for example let's take this
market and imagine the tastes change
suddenly everyone wants to drive big
cars everyone's to drive SUVs okay what
does this do to the market for gas well
so what does this do well what it does
yeah go ahead yes SUVs are what we call
a complement a complement as opposed to
substitute our complement for gasoline
when demand for SUVs goes up demand for
gas goes up so the demand curve would
shift out so we would end up in a
situation like figure 9 - but let's talk
through the dynamics all you would see
in the market is quantity of gas sold
would go up from q1 to q2 and price of
gas would go up from p1 to p2 well let's
talk about underneath how we get there
what happens is demand shifts up people
want more gas because they want to drive
these gas-guzzling cars so she demand
shifts from d1 to d2 what does that mean
that means that at the previous
equilibrium price if the price didn't
change if the price stayed at p1 what
would happen
well we'd no longer be in equilibrium
because people firms would still be
happy to supply q1 units of gas but
people would want way more than that we
would have excess demand if the price
didn't change there would be excess
demand people would want more than the
q1 units of gas suppliers will recognize
this and say well if people want more
we're happy to produce more
but remember we have to respect the
marginal cost curve and marginal costs
of rising if we're gonna produce more
we're gonna have to charge more we're
gonna have to move up the supply curve
so a shift in the demand curve makes
firms move along the supply curve we
want to keep shifts and movement along
curves separate a shift in the demand
curve meaning people are saying to gas
producers we want more gas gas firms
like great we want to give you more gas
but we're gonna have to charge you more
to do it because our marginal cost curve
is upward sloping which is our supply
curve as we learned so the price rises
and we need to reach a new equilibrium
at e2 so we don't see these steps in
practice in the end we just see the
price change but think about it as two
steps demand shifts out creating excess
demand providers to meet that excess
demand have to produce more and to
produce more they're gonna charge a
higher price and that moves you from e1
to e2 okay so we have a shift in demand
which cause to slide up the supply curve
okay now let's think about a different
example imagine war breaks out in the
Middle East not too hard to imagine
unfortunately and as a result the
quantity so suppliers need to pay more
to get the oil that they used to make
gasoline okay what does that do we see
that in Figure 9 3 now what happens is
for every you for every unit of gas
suppliers need to charge more their
underlying marginal costs have gone up
because they have to pay more to get the
oil that's a variable cost of production
of gas so their marginal costs have gone
up their marginal costs going up meaning
their supply curve has shifted upwards
okay for every unit of production their
marginal cost is higher because they're
variable costs have gone up therefore
they're gonna need to charge a higher
price to break-even okay we're still in
perfectly competitive markets where
nobody's making any profit okay they're
gonna charge more to break-even
so now let's once again talk with that
dynamics of what's happening that I
nameks are the cost of and the input to
the suppliers went up Oh
okay they're marginal cost serve shifts
up to s2 so they want to charge a higher
price so if we kept the price the same
as it was before supplies would say we
don't want to sell q1 anymore what I
ain't shouldn't selling q1 anymore
at that old price okay that doesn't
interest us could sue there for
consumers want more than providers are
willing to sell and we once again have
access to mant so we in both cases we
get excess demand in the first case we
got excess demand because consumers
wanted more the lower the consumers
taste shifted so they wanted more gas at
every price now we have excess demand
not cuz taste shift but because costs go
up so providers don't wanna provide as
much gas at every price so what happens
is providers are gonna say fine we're
gonna charge a higher price okay and
we'll slide up the demand curve because
as providers charge a higher price
people want less gas at a higher price
you want less gas through the
substitution effect because you'll buy
other things instead it's the income
effect because you're effectively poorer
because the price of gas went up for
those reasons you're gonna shift up the
demand curve and reach a new equilibrium
and e2 so that's the underlying dynamics
of how shifts in supply and demand lead
to changes in quantity and price okay so
that's basically what we're seeing
questions about that yeah
great great question so what's the
answer how do you what's the
substitution effect with gas well even
it's yourself it's not driving it's
taking the bus it's driving less it's
walking or taking your bike so once
again when everything about substitute
eviction I think about the the
opportunity the next opportunities you
could use instead okay good question
other questions okay so here's an
interesting point look at figure 92 and
93 in both cases the price went up okay
in both case the price went up so we
can't tell if a price goes up you can't
tell from that alone whether there was a
shift in demand or supply so if I for
example asks you on an exam or your mom
came home and your mom asks you hey umm
if the price goes up does that mean
demand shift or supply shifted you say
to your mom I don't know I can't tell
with just that information I knew what
happened to quantity - okay and then you
save your mom good question okay so
let's go through the reasons why the
supply and demand curve shift so why the
curve shift okay
well in the demand side there's at least
six reasons why demand curves would
shift so why do why do you demand curve
shift okay one reason is taste change I
just use that reason taste change
okay people want different things
okay a second reason is that income
changes Zachary's could people are
richer or poorer and so that makes them
want different quantities even with the
same tastes a third reason is the change
the change in the price of a
complimentary or substitutable good okay
now that's different
I should separate the actually example
unifor was this taste change is slightly
different so change in price so come buy
substitute ago is what I talked about
taste change would be literally for
everything held in equal I just wake up
on morning
like to drive that be it takes change
okay
so really this the example I used was to
change the price of complementary no no
please didn't change no I go back I go
back the example I used was at exchange
people wanted more you SUVs but at the
same time imagine different a different
change imagine that we're looking at the
demand for babysitters and the price of
movies goes up
okay well movies are complementary with
babysitters you guys know what about the
scene of kids yet but trust me movies
are complement babysitters that
basically the more you go to the movies
the more you need babysitters so if the
price of movies goes up that's gonna
lower my demand for babysitter's or
vice-versa imagine that how the change
in the price of movies affects the
demand for Netflix well those are
substitutable as the price of movies
goes up I'm gonna want more Netflix and
less babysitters so change in price of
competent or substitutable goods will
also affect my domain curve another
thing that could affect the demand curve
is a change in the market size so we
will talk in a couple lectures about
international trade if suddenly you're
selling goods to a much larger market
that will affect the demand for your
good so preference I haven't changed
price haven't change you just got to
suddenly got a bunch of new customers
that will affect demand for your good
okay and the last thing that could
change the most subtle way demand could
change is expectations of the future so
for example imagine you expect the price
of gas to go up tomorrow you might buy
more gas today and that'll be weird for
the next day you say look nothing
changed today your tastes didn't change
prices nothing change but people buy
more gas what's going on it's that they
expect the price to change in the future
so expectations the future can actually
drive demand today okay we've all
experienced this in very various aspects
of our lives okay so those are the
reasons why the demand curve can shift
so a lot of reasons why the demand curve
could shift for the supply curve wise
supply curve shifts
is sort of much simpler there's really
only two reasons okay
one reason is changes in input costs and
the second reason changes in input costs
and the second is a shift in the
technology and production so the
production function changes or input
costs change that's pretty much why
supply curve shift okay
so that sort of gives you a catalog of
how to think about these curve shifting
I have a fun example in the videos that
go with this class um which is that we
all know Kim Kardashian is you may you
may or may not know she has more
Instagram followers and there are people
in France
she got eighty million about eight it's
up to about a hundred and plus million
Instagram followers Kim Kardashian a few
years ago tweeted out a picture of
herself in an exercise corset she called
it she basically claimed of course it is
this thing nice to wear like back like
when we didn't care about women much at
all and we just made them wear these
incredibly constrictive things to make
them look skinnier okay they're
basically like a like a brace you'd wear
to make you look skinnier back in the
old days and Kim Kardashian said
actually if you were a corset when you
exercise it helps you lose weight well
actually she's totally [ __ ] wrong
okay it doesn't okay there is no it does
not help you lose weight but she tweeted
this out and there was a massive
increase in demand for exercise corsets
okay and the one company that made them
made scads of money there was a huge
demand shift based on this Kim
Kardashian tweet okay so tell me what
happened next yeah
more companies entered okay so what
happened was profits were being made on
exercise corsets so more companies
started making exercise corsets and they
came in and drove those profits down
okay so that's a classic example of how
demand shift and how the market the
long-run will respond to return us to
zero profits see her profits the long
when the short runs of course that money
companies made a lot of money they
should they owe Kim okay but in the long
run profits go to zero yeah yeah
anything where you basically well no but
once that's on that's a price change a
limited time sale for a good is
literally just a standard the price
changed okay it's sort of you think the
sales go up in the future so you buy
less today that's so the expectations
okay so that's shifts in demand supply
curse let's now talk about what
determines the shapes of supply and
demand curve then what determines the
shapes of supply and demand curse okay
so basically the effect not what term is
the shape so we're talking about
determines the shape so one talk about
the role the shapes the supply demand
curves play let me rephrase that we know
what determines the shapes we covered
that the last ten lectures or whatever
now we're talking about the role that
shapes play as demand curve shift so for
example let's think about a Stan word
figure nine three shows what happens
with a supply the figure we're just
looking at okay figure would just look
at that figure nine three shows what
happens when the supply shift with the
standard downward sloping demand curve
okay which is that the price goes up
quantity Falls however imagine instead
we had perfectly inelastic demand so for
example for insulin then what would
happen well figure nine four shows if
demands perfectly inelastic quantity
won't change so if there's a supply if
there's a shock that shifts up the
supply curve like war in the Middle East
so this is the question here why
wouldn't gas just be perfectly inelastic
Allah demand in fact in the short-run
gases
actually pretty you know elastically
demanded okay it's not perfectly
inelastic but it's pretty inelastic okay
so in that case you would see just
prices going up and quantities wouldn't
change now in the long run do we think
the elasticity for gas will be higher or
lower than the short-run the demand
elasticity for gas hi somebody somebody
graze their hand tell me why so every
second tell me why somebody else besides
people always answer questions yeah
people can shift towards electric cars
exactly in the short-run all you can do
is drive less and we got to drive to
work and stuff like that in the long run
I can buy a different car so it's an
example of long run versus short run how
it can affect these elasticity's okay
now let's think instead about a
perfectly perfectly elastic demand the
demand for I don't know you know
tchotchkes in a market or something like
that okay perfectly elastic demand in
figure 9 it's always hard to think of
markets with probably lasted man it's
easy to think about firms having perfect
elastic demand it's hard to think about
markets but think about a market for a
certain kind of candy okay well there's
another kind of cane that's just as good
okay so those are markets which are
fairly elastically demanded okay there
you see when the supply ships price
doesn't change only quantity does and
why is that that's when the demand is
perfectly elastic you can't change the
price if you try to raise price by one
penny you'll lose the entire market if
you lower the price by one penny you
gain the entire market and then you'll
your profits will go away because your
marginal cost will be through the roof
okay so with perfectly elastic demand
okay you're gonna get prices fixed but
only quantity changes okay so basically
that's sort of how we think about these
extremes the bottom line is that's how
the shapes of supply and demand will
affect the response to shocks okay the
more elastically the more elastic is
demand the more price shock will come
through in quantity and lessen prices
the more inelastic is demand the more
supply shock will come through in prices
in nom in quantity okay any questions
about that okay so now let's go on to
what we can do with the supply and
demand curve so now we're where the
Masters is applying two-man curves we
know where they come from we know why
they shape the way they do we
what happens when they shift and we know
what happens how that shift depends on
their shapes so we own supply and demand
curves now let's say what can we do with
them and what we can do with them is use
them to take the next step in this class
from positive to normative economics so
far this class has been completely
focused on positive economics why do
firms behave the way they do
why do consumers behave the way they do
and we haven't talked at all about
whether it's a good thing or a bad thing
well we need a new set of tools if we're
gonna move from positive economics about
why things the way things are turn or
what if he connects about the way they
should be okay and those set of tools
were going to derive from supply and
demand curves and this is critically
important because for example let's take
where we ended the last lecture or the
lectures last lecture I think talking
about how with perfectly or middle last
lecture talking about on a perfectly
competitive market under a set of
assumptions all firms as you're a profit
in the long run okay so we you buy that
that's but you have to ask tough is that
a good thing or a bad thing it's zero
profits long run good or bad well on the
one hand firms are cost minimizing
that's good on the other hand why would
anyone start a business in the long run
they're gonna make no money that's bad
so how do we think about trading those
things off how do we think about whether
it's a good idea or bad to have long run
zero profits okay this is the question
these this set of questions is what we
turn to with with the notion of welfare
economics welfare now welfare what's
going to be used in two senses in this
class mostly when I say welfare I'll
mean as a measure of well-being most
what I say welfare I mean welfare is
well-being sometimes we say welfare we
mean cash payments to poor people
that's like welfare payments that's not
what I mean usually when I say welfare
I'll try to distinguish I mean the other
thing when I say welfare I don't mean
the way it's used in a political debate
meaning cash payments to poor people
I mean welfare is a measure of
well-being and welfare economics is the
tools of normative analysis the tools of
well freakin dogs the tools of measuring
well being and we're gonna start by
talking about the concept of consumer
surplus it's gonna be the first thing
we're gonna use when we talk about
welfare economics is consumer surplus
okay now if we want to measure
well-being however we have a problem
which is how do you measure how happy I
am my noodles but you don't exist so
I've got a fundamental challenge here
which is our indicator of well-being as
utility function which isn't a real
thing
okay we use it to derive decisions but
we don't actually have a measure of
well-being that gives real meaningful
inputs so what do we do we you a clever
thing economists thought of a long time
ago which is to use the concept of
compensating variation the concept of
compensating variation was that concept
means that means that instead of asking
you how happy you are I ask you how much
would I have to pay you to become less
set to become sadder or how much would
you be willing to pay to be happier so I
can't measure margin jillion dollars but
I can measure how many dollars you would
pay to buy the next good or how many
dollars you pay me not to be punched or
whatever okay I can basically measure
those things by essentially ask asking
you how much would you pay to be better
off or how much would you be willing to
pay not to be worse off and those are
what we call dative compensating
variation we measure your well-being by
the money equivalent that you give to us
okay in expressing your preferences and
what we can then define consumer surplus
will define consumer surplus which is
our first measure of normative welfare
economics as the benefit that it
consumer gets from consuming a good
above and beyond the price of that good
the benefit that a consumer gets from
consuming a good above and beyond what
they
for that good that's consumer surplus
surplus means extra right so it's your
extra it's how much more you get that
when you had what you actually had to
pay to get the good in the first place
okay so basically um consider my
daughter's demand for songs by Kendrick
Lamar
okay um let's and let's to make life
easy let's say this is pre streaming and
songs cost a dollar okay so she wants
songs by Kendrick Lamar it's actually so
let's actually yeah see what sort of
icons Lamar and there's no streaming and
she and the songs cost a dollar so if my
daughter's willing to pay a dollar for
Kendrick Lamar song and it costs a
dollar then her consumer surplus is zero
she's will heard the benefit she gets
from the song as a dollar it costs a
dollar her zero but if she was willing
to pay two dollars for Kendrick Lamar
song and all it cost a dollar then she's
got a dollar in surplus okay so
basically the key thing is to define
consumer surplus we need two things the
price and the willingness to pay well
how the hell do we get willingness to
pay where does that come from some raise
their head and tell me yeah the demand
curve we are defined it we are defined
what will is toupees it's the demand
curve so consumer surplus is simply
defined as the area below the demand
curve above the price because that tells
you the demand curve tells you how much
you're willing to pay for each unit the
price new face tells you how much you
had to pay so any gap between them is
consumer surplus okay so let's go to
figure nine six let's do my daughter's
demand for Kendrick Lamar songs okay
let's say that her demand is such that
now once again the trick here is we've
drawn a continuous demand curve it's a
discrete decision so sort of bear with
me the numbers you know bear with me as
you think about this but roughly
speaking she's willing to pay for the
first Kendrick Lamar song
between four and five dollars okay for
the next Kendrick Lamar song's gonna pay
between three and four dollars for the--
and so on
so this gives you so let's to make life
easy let's imagine willing to pay four
dollars for the first Kendrick Lamar
song three dollars for the second
Kendrick Lamar song two dollars for the
third Kendrick Lamar song and four
dollars for the first country and four
I'm sorry in one dollar for the fourth
Kendrick Lamar song okay so imagine
that's basically her demand curve it's
not quite that discreet but we could
make it stepwise if you want just be
ugly-looking okay
so that's her demand curve so what does
that mean that means that when she buys
the fourth Kendrick Lamar song okay when
she buys King [ __ ] or whatever that is
zero surplus okay zero surplus she was
willing to pay a dollar for King Kunta
and she and it cost a dollar so she's
done okay however what does that mean
that means when she bought Humble which
was her first chor song okay she gained
a surplus because she paid a dollar for
that
but she was willing to pay four dollars
for it so she gained a surplus and the
surplus is the difference between what
she paid which is represented by the
horizontal line and a dollar and what
she was willing to pay which is a demand
curve which is four dollars so she
gained that surplus yeah it's a great
question is a famous article about that
I'll come back to that in one minute let
me finish this the bottom line is the
surplus there's been what she was
willing to pay and what she had to pay
which in the continuous example is this
entire triangle think of by being able
to buy fractions of songs
okay little little bits ringtones or
whatever okay fractions of songs okay
then this entire area under the curve
above the price is her surplus she was
willing to pay the points on the curve
she only had to pay the flat line at a
dollar so the entire difference is her
surplus
okay the key point is this is all driven
by diminishing marginal utility that is
the reason her surplus goes to zero or
eventually is because eventually gets
tired of Kendrick Lamar songs so it goes
down we have diminishing margin Chile
for the songs and that's why we get
consumer surplus as a triangle it's the
difference between the downward sloping
demand curve and the flat price line
that the consumer faces okay so the
individual consumer surplus individual
consumer surplus okay it's hurt him as
an individual graph okay individual
graph per demand is downward sloping and
therefore her surplus difference between
is the area under the demand curve above
the price line yeah let's talk about
that let's let's talk about um actually
I don't have it here if the man was
Hurley inelastic you're absolutely right
the consumer surplus would be infinite
because the area under the demand curve
above the price line would be infinity
to be a rectangle go up to infinity why
is that why is the consumer surplus
infinite if demands inelastic because
they pay anything for it
so at any price it's a bargain in theory
if you're if you're incredibly rich
diabetic you would pay an infinite
amount to have insulin so at any price
you're getting huge surplus you're
getting infinite circles infinity minus
anything is infinity likewise what's the
consumer surplus if demand is perfectly
elastic same person what zero why that's
graphically why but intuitively why why
do you get no surplus from a good where
demands fairly elastic
what what makes a perfectly elastic
demand curve because why as their
substitutes that you're indifferent
towards that's what gets a perfectly
last demand
so if I'm indifferent between jujyfruits
god you got spot-on jujyfruits
if I'm a different between god only know
what candy is anymore
whatever I mean everything candy and
candy be okay and then I get no surplus
from consuming candy a why because I'm
equally happy with candy B so candy a
gives me no surplus what is the candy
people eat what do people eat what Jolly
ranks I love Jolly Ranchers okay yeah
well no but that's that's irrelevant cuz
skittles are just disappointing M&Ms
let's be honest when you get skittles
you just pissed off the non M&Ms am i
right I mean skittles is 220 M&Ms so we
can't do that one let's do sort of you
know Jolly Ranchers versus skittles
maybe those are more comparable cuz M&Ms
are better than everything so basically
Jolly rationed skittles since I get
since I'm indifferent Jolly Ranchers and
skittles I get no surplus trimming the
skittles cuz I would Etha happy having a
jolly rancher so surplus is zero for a
perfectly lastly demand good it's
infinite for a perfectly inelastic they
demand a good okay now let's go back to
the question there's a famous article in
economics called the deadweight loss of
Christmas we're such an awful profession
based about how terrible gift giving is
and wise gift giving terrible because if
you gave people cash they could get what
they want the most but if you give them
a gift it's by definition lower surplus
than the cash because they could always
go out and buy that good with the cash
so by definition giving someone a gift
makes them worse off they giving them
that same amount of cash so this guy
does the interview to all the students I
think was at Penn State and he asked
them how much their parents presents
really worth to them and he found the
deadweight loss of Christmas like
hundreds of billions of dollars but like
he would way rather have cash than the
parents but what did he get wrong what
did he get wrong why is that not why is
that nicely a bad thing yeah you ask the
first question so go ahead
maybe but even ignoring that what else
did he get wrong yeah that's um like the
surprise there's emotional connections
that's all well and good but that's not
very big okay what's really big that he
missed yeah he missed the fact the
person who gave it gets utility from
giving it so in fact the package may be
efficient because you're like the
surprising because the person gets
utility but if you compared to dollars
it's inefficient so it's kind of a
clever clever little exercise he did um
okay so basically that's individual
consumer surplus but in this course we
don't care about individual consumer
surplus we care about market consumer
surplus so let's turn to figure nine
seven and think about a market listen
about the market for gas
now the mechanics is the same here but
we're actually now thinking not about
the individual buying one gallon versus
two gallons but the market for gas how
many gallons in aggregate will be bought
but the analysis is the same okay that
basically the willingness to pay for gas
is the demand curve for gas the market
demand curve for gas the price is the
price so the difference is the area
under the demand curve above the price
the idea here is for consumers all the
way to the left
they have to drive to work they have to
drive to have to drive a lot they're
truck drivers or whatever they've drive
a lot so for them they have a huge
willingness to pay for gas so they make
a huge surplus the more you want
something you've given price the more
circles you get where's you move to the
right that's who will need to drive less
and less
once you pass point a why does surplus
go away to the right of point a wise to
know more consumer surplus yeah didn't
happen because
your willingness to pay is below the
price right so transaction so consumer
surplus can't go negative
but when negative just wouldn't buy it
so let's see his negative consumer
surplus okay when negative you just
wouldn't buy it okay but but as you get
closer and closer to a then you actually
do end up with consumer surplus going to
zero okay so that's the UM that sort of
mark consumer surplus so let's ask what
let's let's talk about um a couple of
aspects of our consumer surplus first
question what happens to consumer
surplus when the price changes let's
show that in Figure nine eight
let's say the price of gas goes up from
$3 to 350 a gallon consumer surplus
shrinks by consumer surplus shrinks by a
trapezoid consumer surplus used to be
the entire area below the demand curve
it used to be the entire area below the
demand curve and above $3 so used to be
that whole triangle now it's just the
empty triangle above the new price curve
and below the demand curve so the new
consumer surplus is just the area above
350 on demand curves does the area not
shaded in what you've lost is the
trapezoid that goes that on the y-axis
goes between 3 and 350 and then along
the along the line goes from A to B
you've lost that trapezoid why is it a
trapezoid why have you lost why why is
the lost consumer surplus a trapezoid
because two things have happened what
are the two things that have happened
that have reduced your consumer surplus
get some more folks involved folks you
know good doctors quantity supplied
quantity sold goes down because you want
less supply because you are so the first
thing is because the price gone up you
want less that's the triangle you lost
you have given up units that you used to
get surplus on used to derive surplus on
all the units from 900 to a thousand so
what happened here is the price goes up
and a hundred fewer people buy gas
that's the way I've ladies that could be
people buy less gas let's make it easy
hundred people buy gas so hundred people
used to buy gas no longer buy gas
they're out of
gasps market.they bike instead okay now
they clearly were not that sad to bike
or they would've had huge surplus from
gas but they're little sad to bike gets
crappy day out they ravage driving and
so they lost surplus from the fact that
now at the higher price they have to
bike instead but it's a little bit of
surplus it's just a little triangle okay
so it's a little bit of surplus loss
because some people who are close to and
different now have to bike instead of
driving but why the big what the big
what's the big rectangle same person
what caused a big rectangle increase in
price for who for the people who are
already buying it anyway
so the big losers are the people are
going to drive anyway and now just have
to pay more for it because they because
here's the key point the people between
a and B people the last hundred people
they were pretty close to indifferent
they didn't lose that much surplus I'm
not driving all the people to the left
of person nine hundred they get big
surplus from driving so their surplus
simply went down by this rectangle they
used to get the difference between the
demand curve and three dollars not
leaders to demand curve in 350 it's just
a pure loss so when you raise a price
the existing the people whose behavior
doesn't change are worse off sometimes
behavior change they're a little worse
off but not that much so the triangle
small the rectangles big the big loss is
the people who like gas a lot but not to
pay more for it okay point one point two
what determines whether consumer surplus
is large or small well we cover this
it's elasticity of demand determines
whether consumer surplus is large or
small so for example figure nine nine
takes the gas market with a price of
three and a thousand people buying gas
and uses two shows two different demand
curves both of which go through point a
so both demand curves yield the
equilibrium price of three and the
equilibrium quantity of a thousand okay
so these two different Amman curves are
just two different sets of preferences
both of which yield the same equilibrium
outcome and yet under the steeper demand
curve the consumer surplus is larger
that under the flatter cut
man kerf and that's for the reason we
talked about that's for the reason
that's because with the steeper demand
curve the more inelastic demand people
want the good more they basically
they're less willing to give it up as
the price goes up therefore at any price
they're making more surplus often with
the flatter demand curve people are
basically closer to indifferent with
some other good so they're not so sad if
the price goes up their surplus is
smaller from getting this good there's
even what that we're willing to pay and
what they have to pay is smaller okay so
that's how we think about consumer
surplus it's basically the excess of
your willingness to pay above what you
have to pay so the price goes up your
surplus goes down and surplus is larger
the more inelastic is is the demand
curve yeah great question when we talk
about monopolies right now
why can't producers do that why can't
producers exploit that because perfectly
yeah exactly
cuz there that's a perfect answer to a
perfectly competitive question cuz their
price takers okay
so they can't do an exploiting of
consumers they don't have that choice
mmm starting next lecture one lecture
after we'll talk about monopolies then
their price setters then they'll start
thinking about that but right now they
can't because the price takers I mean
ultimately that's with it yeah
ultimately they'd like the cert the
surplus is just extra money somebody's
got if you're a business owner why
should consumers have it there you know
you want it okay so that's um so that's
consumer surplus any other questions
about consumer surplus okay now let's
move on and let's talk about producer
surplus
let's talk about producer surplus okay
now the idea here is the same consumer
surplus was the difference between the
willingness to pay for a good and its
price producer surplus is the difference
between the willingness supply a good
and its price and how do we measure
willing to supply the supply curve so
figure as figure 9/10 shows the producer
surplus
for any given firm for any given firm
okay
firms have an upward sloping supply
curve and the market is delivering them
some price so let's think about this
firm when they produce the first unit
this think this is a gas production firm
okay a gas refiners say when they refine
that first gallon of gas okay
that costs them almost nothing because
marginal costs upward sloping they've
already paid the fixed costs they don't
care in the short-run so I like ever
this variable costs okay so in the end
of the day this is not expensive they
are willing to prove that first gallon
really cheaply they've already invested
in this giant refinery plant marginal
costs are tiny so they get a huge but at
the same time you pay them you don't
differentiate what you pay per gallons
you go to you plug the thing into your
car and you get the gas okay so they're
getting three bucks a gallon but they're
not paying much to make that gallon
however as they make more gallons their
marginal cost increases so the surplus
they earn on each gallon produced
shrinks the surplus they earn at each
gallon produced shrinks and so
eventually they get to a point where
they are essentially indifferent about
producing the next unit of gasoline
that's at a price of $3 and a quantity
of should be little Q okay that's the
point at which they are indifferent okay
between producing producing gas and a
producing gas therefore their surplus is
zero so producer surplus is the
difference between the price line and
the upward sloping supply curve is
pretty surplus now in the long run
we have a name for that it's called
profits
okay so while consumer surplus is this
sort of abstract weird theoretical
concept pretty surplus you can get your
hands around its profits basically in
the long run remember in the long run
marginal cost equals average cost right
because in the long run you produce
until marginal cost equals average cost
therefore the supply curve is the
average cost curve price minus average
cost as profits
therefore producer surpluses profits let
me say it again little three line proof
for you okay in the long run marginal
cost equals average costs second the
supply curve is the marginal cost curve
therefore it's the average cost curve
third profits is defined as price minus
average cost fourth profits is the
shaded area now in the short-run that's
not quite right
because there's the whole shutdown
decision which makes things awkward but
roughly speaking it's not terrible to
think about producer surplus as being
profits that's a shorthand that largely
works if it ever doesn't work we'll let
you know but that's a shorthand should
largely work okay now of course once
again we don't care about individual
firms producer surplus we care about the
market briefs or surplus so let's go to
figure 911 figure 911 is basically the
market surplus curve and the idea here
is that essentially to the left you you
have a market supply curve where
basically remember the individual firms
supply curve is always flat but the
market supply curve doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be flat okay the
market supply curve
well note let me back up a market supply
curve is flat under certain set of
conditions but now let's imagine that
those conditions aren't true for example
let's go back to I talked at the end of
last lecture about heterogeneous firms
when we took the cotton example some
firms are more efficient producers than
others if all firms are identical it's
hardly competitive of course the market
supply curve is flat since this graph
would be uninteresting but in fact
imagine that firms aren't identical some
firms are more efficient producers than
others okay for example in that case
what you'll see is the most efficient
producer will earn the most surplus EE
ie the most profit there all the way to
the left
as you move to the right you're getting
to less and less efficient producers
okay so profit is shrinking so under the
conditions we started with last time
then price would always equal supply be
a flat supply curve at the price and
therefore profits are zero that is
producer surplus is zero so we we
derived towards the end of the last
election we said in the long run a
perfectly competitive market profit is
zero that's the same as saying producer
surplus is zero and why is that
that's because in that case the price
line is on top of the supply curve
therefore there's no gap between them so
in the long run in a perfectly
competitive market there's zero producer
surplus means zero profit in reality we
talked about conditions why there would
be an upward sloping long run supply
curve like firms different how efficient
they are or where there's barriers to
entry which means some firms can't come
in and drive profits to zero or there's
an upward sloping input price curve
meaning that basically the more you want
to produce the more you have to pay
workers for all those reasons the supply
curve slopes up and therefore you can
get a producer surplus you can get some
profits even the long-run okay so
basically what we have here is a
situation where as long as the supply
curve slopes up you get a long-run
producer surplus which is the difference
between the price and the supply curve
okay and that is the same as profits
questions about that okay let me cover
one last point going back to last
lecture didn't have time to get to a
last lecture remember we talked about
three reasons why in the long run even
even in a competitive market supply
could give slope up we talked about
heterogeneous firms that is firms with
different levels of efficiency of
production we talked about barriers to
entry that is reasons why firms can't
enter and drive profits to zero because
it's not costless to enter and we talked
about upward sloping input supply curves
we talked about the fact that as you
produce more you might have to pay more
for your inputs and therefore you can't
just charge one you have to charge the
you have to charge higher prices as you
produce more
I want to highlight so they said quickly
last time difference between these two
and this one in these two there are
profits and these two there are profits
okay
because then each of these their reasons
why the market will not drive every firm
to zero profit some furs will remain in
much like Pakistan made profits on their
cotton sales some froze Romanian
likewise with the barriers to entry the
firm's that have that are in the market
that have gotten over those barriers
will make money okay in this case the
firm doesn't necessarily make money okay
what it does here is it just pays it
takes that extra money and pays it out
to workers okay so whether or not an
upward sloping supply curve doesn't
necessarily mean the firm makes profit
it could just be upward sloping because
their input costs are rising okay so
that's sort of an important distinction
to keep in mind so let's stop there with
that mind-blowing insight let's stop
there and we will come back and we'll
talk more about welfare economics